Wow it feels totally different on this
side of the glass excuse me big Tony hey
you still I didn't shanks in that beard
you know it my man big Tony wit is that
guy client big Tony imagine that I would
never represent big Tony that guy's
guilty is I don't how do you know we
were cellmates you would will you laughs
we were cellmates great exchange rate
for cigarettes to dental floss to Lucy's
full spool cinnamon mint I thought why
wasn't but you were in prison yeah where
do you think I got my law degree
kick-ass library at this prison kick-ass
I don't believe this I couldn't believe
it either a good prison library I mean
this is the last place that gets state
funding but say had a Barney for me man
he runs book town prison lingo
you'll get it I would prefer not to get
the lingo I want to get out of here and
I would also prefer not to have a lawyer
who's an ex-con come on man all lawyers
are criminals
you see what I'm charging you that's
highway robbery I can't believe that
didn't get a laugh yeah this isn't
making me trust you come on there are a
lot of advantages to having a lawyer
that's been in prison I mean I know all
the inside tips like don't drop your
soap around white Kevin if you know what
I mean he steals soap he's a so Porter I
think he's making a chessboard what were
you in prison for racketeering yeah
represented myself turns out there's no
good defense against racketeering but
that's wrong charge with yo Ricardo
what's up don't think I forgot about you
how long I'm gonna works nightmare I set
you said you were gonna jump me but I'm
on the outside now how do you like that
laughs pendejo yes
the only way you can earn me is hurting
somebody I care about that's on the
inside but the only person like that and
I can think of is this client but you're
probably too much of a poke [ __ ] to
jump a doe a leprechaun mother like that
this [ __ ] that doe a leprechaun
mother we got a day football don't
forget don't forget what are you doing
you're gonna want to join a gang
I recommend the skulls with hats LAN are
you pure white